of Ukraine
it was rock star stuff they acclaimed
the president dressed in khaki
fresh from the war zone to The Well of
the house chamber with an assessment
from the front line
you green is alive
and Kicking
he might not have spotted the
Republicans who sat when everyone else
stood but he did address concerns over
usaid to Ukraine thank you it wasn't
charity he said but an investment for
his country and for those he spoke of a
turning point in 2023 next year will be
a turning point I know it the point when
Ukrainian courage and American resolve
director of our common freedom
earlier in the day at the White House
there had been a comforting hand from
the president and a handout you are the
man of the year to the Ukrainian he
hailed as U.S Man Of The Year the U.S
president pledged a patriot missile
defense system we're going to continue
to strengthens Ukraine's ability to
defend itself particularly air defense
and that's why we're going to be
providing Ukraine with Patriot missile
batter
zelenski's first foreign trip since
conflict began took place amidst the
tightest security it began in darkness
at the Polish border and continued in a
U.S military plane under escort by NATO
Jets
the reassurance he received here of
continued support will matter to
president zielinski what will matter
more is the Pledge of military hardware
he takes home specifically Patriot
missiles a defensive Shield as Russia
targets his country's infrastructure
from the air
zelenski isn't the first wartime leader
in Wartime to address a joint session of
Congress Winston Churchill came before
him in 1941 during the second World War
there was no Handover of a battlefield
flag in his day the choreography might
have changed in 81 years but warnings of
tyranny remain the same
James Matthews Sky News Washington